[Music]
homie look what I become
you have to be you just have to know at
the email to see it says add Instagram
if not it is fraud anyways hey it's good
to uh have you guys here with us on this
podcast this special podcast
with somebody that is making a Major
Impact around the world with her story
a timely story for many of us in America
who need to hear this story who don't
think your freedoms can be taken away
from you uh last time her and I got
together and we sat down and spoke with
us a few years ago uh the amount of uh
interest in the story and what happened
with it was uh unbelievable and uh her
first book was a major bestseller and
she's got a new one that's coming out
called while time remains a North Korean
Defector search for freedom in America
the one and only yomi Park how are you
I'm good thank you for having me on this
case Vinnie's very happy to be sitting
next to you just so you I don't want to
see something he's been asking about
this yeah and there was a fight and then
when he said I have to sit next to her
but we're very happy to have you here oh
thank you thank you for welcoming so you
know there's a lot of things we'll cover
today some people don't know your story
we have some stories that we want to
talk about something that happened in
Russia that hasn't happened since the
70s something Russia did that they
haven't done since the 70s which is
pretty wild it has to do with
preparation for a big war a World War
III type of War especially after uh
Biden visited Ukraine this uh this last
week instead of going to East Palestine
we'll talk about that we'll talk about
some of the things that's going on with
Don um how do you say his last name Don
Lemon
we'll talk about him killing it uh
DeSantis and Trump going back and forth
the name calling and at the same time
the Santa's doing his part I'd like to
get your thoughts on that with uh uh
woke agenda what's going on with schools
I got a couple videos I want to show you
to get your reaction on that and then
Tom's got some stories on Disney that he
wants to comment on Elon Musk declares
canceled culture over since Twitter
takeover uh he says you won't be missed
I'm curious to know if you agree with
Elon whether cancel culture is over or
not and then a couple other fun stories
uh one Tiger Woods I don't know if you
know what Tiger Woods did this last week
did you hear about the story or no have
you heard about his uh what he did to
one of his competitors you have to hear
the story to know to get your reaction
on it anyways having said that yomi if
you don't mind
um last time we spoke a lot about your
story yeah and the audience knows your
story but some of the people that are
new audiences that are with us that may
not know your story would you mind
taking a minute and sharing your
background with the audio
yeah it's a where do I even begin
I was born in North Korea and not
knowing that I was born in the most
oppressed country I think that's how I
tell Americans when they say they're
oppressed like if you know you're
oppressed you're not oppressed like not
knowing is the definition of Oppression
I believe I was living in the best
country on Earth it was a socialist
paradise and I had to sing a song called
nothing to Envy because we were living a
socialist Paradise
so I I think with that just have no idea
what was going on in the world uh when I
was 13 years old I just couldn't simply
find any more food
so that led me to escape to China
then uh crossing the golbi desert into
Mongolia after two years then go to
South Korea and then five years after I
came to America all while you're how old
it was from me 13 to 15 I was crossing
the desert and then come to America when
I was 21 years old that's unbelievable
you know when people hear a story like
that how often you know me when you tell
your story people almost don't believe
it they think it's like you're just
telling a story there's no way that
story is real yesterday I posted a
picture of me in the military and I post
a couple pictures in the Army and I'll
get messages people say that picture
doesn't look like you that's not you and
I'll say hey I was born and raised in
Iran and you know here's what Iran was
like when we're getting bombed there's
no way that's true you're just telling
the story out of Argo how often do you
hear people say you know yummy you can't
tell me it was that bad
so in some sense I think I got lucky
because a I mean remember when Americans
uh is tourists or one beer from the
Virginia Tech University he went to
North Korea and then he was sentenced
for heart live for 15 years for stealing
a banner
and then they tortured him and they
rearranged his Tech like old teeth and
then he came out of the vegetable state
that Trump like brought him back so I
think American understood like if that's
what they do to American white men yeah
I mean they can't even imagine what they
would do to their own people
so I think when it comes to North Korean
issue at least still the between
Democrats and the Republicans understand
the complete Black nobody argues it's
somehow great
and but how they want to approach some
of the problem is different so then then
you know for for some again the question
why are you so optimistic though you
know when I see you and I met you we
went to lunch afterwards you had very
nice things to say about Adam you
thought Adam was part of the lgbtq
community
I don't know if you remember this or not
oh yeah
oh that was her that was her she asked
Adam if Adam's gay she said you said
you're very nice and you dress well so
you must be gay I was like I will show
you who's not gay right now
not that there's anything wrong with
that anyways but but we are friends
we're good but you were you're always
optimistic your personality you seem
like you were have the attitude of
future looks bright but then at the same
time you have the uh you know the
perspective you present of hey let's
stay paranoid because we don't know what
could happen here even in America how do
you balance that level of optimism with
the life that you've lived and have a
little bit of paranoia to say we got to
keep fighting for this freedom
yeah I think in general more optimists I
think there are only just two over 200
defectors made it to America over the
last eight years
say that one part again over the last 80
years only 209 nursing defectors make
America over the last 80 years 209 may
have made it to America that's intense
yeah yeah and I'm one of them wow that's
right and they made it pretty hard right
I mean it's now it's almost impossible
like they set up land mines and electric
fence and like he's it's made it yeah
it's impossible to get up that was
actually a question for you and me uh
the Escape process I know we have a lot
of stuff we want to get through today
but just the Escape process when you did
it how difficult was just that component
of it and how more difficult how much
more difficult would it be now
so my time was like every 10 meters with
the actual human guard with the machine
gun standing there every 10 meters it
was a human guard but now actually China
gave them the technology of the facial
recognition camera
everywhere on Chinese side and North
Korean side both they put the
electrified wire fences and they buried
the landmines to kill his own people and
then he actually put the people moved
away from the border towns okay so now
it's literally impossible literally
when's the last time someone escaped
ah like I don't know so keep the ones
that don't even let one single ant cross
between borders wow and when you escape
you said there was a soldier every 10
meters I assume you did it in the dark
how did you disguise yourself how did
you uh go under the radar so to speak so
the reason how I didn't get shot was the
people were happy meal the traffickers
they were selling us to human
traffickers in China so they bribed the
guards but the problem was they're every
10 meters you cannot drive all of them
it's too expensive so they bribed one
guard and that post so we could always
shot from other posts
so that's why it was very dangerous
yeah this by the way if you haven't
watched the entire episode that her and
I went through the story is
a lot darker and deeper than we have to
get into today because there's so many
things that's happened from the last
time we spoke to today that I want to
get your opinions on what's going on
with current events I think that's uh
very important for us to cover and then
obviously we'll put the link below for
the audience to get as well so let's go
into the first story the first story I
saw with um
uh uh Elon Musk that came out and you
know he said Elon Musk declares cancel
culture is over since Twitter takeover
and that's one of the things you speak
out about a lot and here's what he said
let me just read this story to you uh
Elon the CEO of Twitter recently
declared that cancel culture is over
just months after his uh takeover the
social media company he made the comment
on Tuesday following in exchange between
journalist Matt haibi and Joe Rogan on
Rogan's podcast Joe Rogan shared on the
podcast that people aren't scared to
speak their mind on Twitter and you're
seeing so much pushback since musk's
acquisition they're not worried about
losing their account which they were
before broken out of taibi who helped
publish some of musk's Twitter files
said I hope people are feeling
encouraged to say more now when musk
bought Twitter in October of 2022 for 44
billion he promised to protect free
speech on the platform saying that
Twitter is the digital Town Square where
matters vital to the future of humanity
are debated must get previously declared
that cancel culture needs to be canceled
and he's saying now it's officially
canceled do you think cancer culture is
officially canceled
as a moment of yesterday I guess
yeah as of right now do you think do you
think right now people the whole concept
of worrying about getting your channel
shut down or your YouTube or your
Twitter account taken away from your
Facebook you know now that Trump got
Twitter back you got Facebook back you
got all of these accounts back do you
think the days of being afraid of
speaking out or behind us
that's interesting because I my posters
shows as a sensitive post to a lot of my
followers on Twitter or yeah on Twitter
really actually on Twitter interesting
yeah so even till this morning so I'm
like why can't I see her post so it's a
real comments I get you guys don't get
that
no of course you're talking about Shadow
Banning oh yeah yeah if you you post
then it's a sensitive material oh yeah
on Twitter yeah on Facebook absolutely I
don't see it on Twitter tweets so my
followers keep saying that like why
can't I see this post so like I think
maybe at least 30 percent does that yeah
yeah it's fun because I I posted
something on Instagram and then a bunch
of people and had nothing to do with
covet but it kept putting this the covet
warning how recent was that this was
about a week week and a half ago and it
was absolutely nothing about covid but
people are like why do we see this it's
a comedy sketch about something
completely different but Instagram is
still putting that tag on instagram is
uh Facebook is uh I don't know if
YouTube is doing anything with it but
YouTube will still comment on hey this
one a little bit too far or you know
certain things would say do you think
cancel culture is over with I think this
is uh what is known as a self-fulfilling
prophecy that our friend Elon Musk is
you is you know reaching out for I don't
I think we're starting to see the
infancy stages of cancel culture like
this anti-woke agenda that Ron DeSantis
and certain other people are sort of
spearheading no I don't think cancel
culture is over and I'll tell you why
because you also have tens of millions
of gen Z for the most part who are the
kickstarters of cancel culture and
they're not going anywhere and they're
doubling down on some of their things
that they believe in their ideology
whether it's sort of the LGBT stuff or
whether it's the uh critical race Theory
or whether it's a 1619 project these
things aren't going anywhere what I
think will help identify sort of like
the canary in the coal mine of what
where cancel culture will be is the 2024
election we'll see where that kind of
goes because I think if it is Ron
DeSantis or even Trump on the right
versus whoever ends up being on the left
if it's a Biden or a Newsom or a comler
whoever uh I think that'll be sort of an
identifier but no I do not think that it
is it is over I think even within
Twitter it is not over I think that he's
done a good job of making it more of a
free speech platform but I think he's
still removed Kanye I think there's some
certain things so he didn't remove Kanye
he's suspended yeah yeah and by the way
same thing I don't think it is though I
think uh I think I think that is like uh
uh there's a difference between getting
your license suspended and taken away
right if you get like listen I had 21
speeding tickets one day I'm driving
with a guy I'm trying to teach him how
to sell insurance policies this is 18
years ago 17 years ago cop pulls me over
says what are you doing I said I'm on
the 101 freeway I'm trying to get to a
client's house he says what are you
doing driving with a suspended license I
say I don't even know if my license been
suspended your license is suspended for
a year I have to get out of the car
somebody ought to come pick me up take
me guess what yes I deserve to have my
license suspended at the time but then I
got it back and then I lost it again I
got it back again eventually yeah I'm
driving right cancel culture I think
when Elon is saying this
he may be right uh uh in because to him
think about if you're Elon Musk Elon
Musk is for sure cancel culture is for
sure canceled for him on Twitter 100
percent
for sure it's canceled for him on
Twitter now do I think it's
um
decreased on Twitter yes 100 do I think
people are saying stuff on Twitter that
they couldn't get away with you know a
year ago one million percent I don't
think he could have gone away with it
six months ago on Twitter do I think
some things are broken because the new
Engineers I'll give you an idea we have
a app that we develop Tom knows the
story so we uh moved away from one of
the uh developers that we hired we moved
away to a bigger developer because of a
team of 500 people and they can do stuff
for us that the other guys couldn't do
the new Developers
updated seven different things that
worked incredibly well but they broke
two things I wasn't that was working
well yeah I don't know if that makes
sense yeah yeah seven things work sick
but two things that were not broken they
broke it by trying to fix seven other
things so I think elon's Tesla Engineers
or whoever he brought in right now may
be breaking some stuff while fixing 80
things and I think the users have to be
a little bit patient but people are not
afraid of saying stuff today then they
were afraid of six months ago well Adam
made a great point but let's just say
Trump wins in 2024 you don't think I
know they're cleaning up and all these
Twitter files and the FBI is embedded
and FBI is going to Twitter and
monitoring for a political party you
don't think they're still going to be
there when if let's say Trump wins those
people are still there the FBI to me is
all left all Democrat voting I remember
that one time asked how many Republicans
are actually in the FBI when the FBI is
that involved bro that cancel it's going
to come back you'll see let me uh I
don't necessarily agree that all the FBI
or the CIA is all Democrat I don't think
about the majority of the majority
however what I do want to ask since
you're a comedian is
how many times can you be canceled what
do I mean we just saw that Roseanne Barr
Roseanne Arnold or whatever you know she
goes by these days Roseanne was canceled
yeah right a few years back and now
she's on tour again and her whole thing
is well you can't cancel me again yeah
it's like even Andrew Tate is an example
it's like I've already been canceled the
Matrix has used all their bullets well
now they've used another one he's in
jail but can you get canceled again I
guess is the question you just nailed it
though she was canceled remember she did
the national anthem and she like mocked
it that was one of the first cats yeah
they were like you're done they just
laughed at her canceled no America when
they pull you off of your show they they
remove you from your platform you're
done that's what happened with Roseanne
I I think you make a good point about
the 2024 election Adam is that we're
gonna see how does the populists really
think about candidates and about what
they stand for for these kind of things
and that's going to show up but I think
Elon Musk was saying is I can't read his
mind but the way I read it is Council
culture has done it Twitter I'm done
taking orders from the outside we're
trying to fix things and do it and I
think he was very adamant about that and
I think he's also saying you know and
I'm not going away and I think it was a
vision statement for the rest of us
because I see it's not getting better
you know
um everywhere certain places it's
getting better everybody is like oh
change the leadership at YouTube Maybe
maybe this is a sign that some things
are going to be different maybe you can
have an opinion on covid that won't get
shut down at YouTube and I think so I
that's why I read it Pat I read it kind
of as a vision statement and I'm not
going away and cancel culture is done at
Twitter and he knows his impact
on the rest of the world he's an
influencing voice so that's kind of the
way around I'll say something here and
you and me if you've got any thoughts we
can go to the next story so here's one
thing I will say I think when you know
it is Facebook Instagram everybody kind
of given uh Trump uh uh uh reinstating
him on the accounts I think a lot of
these guys and including YouTube maybe
firing Susan the CEO of YouTube maybe a
lot of these guys are sitting there
saying dude let's just make sure they
don't Target and find out our freaking
YouTube files what if they find a
Facebook files and Instagram files holy
[__] if they figure this part out so
listen let's kind of accommodate let's
kind of slow our role on the strikes and
the Banning and this and that and let's
kind of let people lose a little bit
more let's kind of know that this is
going to be the year of Investigations
fauci and Twitter files and you know uh
Biden and Hunter Biden and all they're
going to be investigating everybody
let's just pump the brakes the people
that were committing the crime I think
they kind of want to be away from all
the um what do you call it the
investigations that's taking place if
you look at the social media influencers
you'll notice a couple different things
watch how the loud mouth nft people how
loud they were a year and a half ago
look how quiet they are today
let's see Whispers how a year ago nfts
were the greatest things in sliced bread
they're so quiet and they're talking
about kindness and they're saying hey
yeah that's just countable love roll and
it's all about love and you know what
they're trying to say please love me and
leave me alone with the money that I
made selling all these nfts to people
that 99 of them are a waste of time I
think that's kind of what's happening
however here's the thing from an Iranian
and somebody was from North Korea and
somebody who struggled growing up in
Miami you know we have to know that you
have to Forever
and ever fight for freedom of speech I
don't think there's ever going to be a
time where cancel culture is canceled I
don't think there will ever ever be a
time where you're going to be free of
that ever what are your thoughts yeah I
mean totally actually you mentioned
about FBI I was invited to speak at FBI
Dallas last year oh and then like to be
to this right before my event the head
of diversity towards me
and then she calls me my political
opinions are too controversial so she
has cancer me get out of here Bingo at
FBI I told you but we agreed that I'm
gonna only speak about my experience
from North Korea nothing about American
politics just my journey to Freedom
and they still didn't let you no in
Dallas
which is in Texas which is still a rich
State I know yeah so that's very weird
what was the justification if I was I
was not diverse enough I'm in the head
of diversity I'm an Asian Defector North
Korea yeah you're not diverse enough
yeah what does that mean exactly
my I think they are looking for maybe
like skin color of diversity right but
my thoughts were too controversial in
her mind that I I don't know what it was
just caused me like your your political
opinions literally these political
opinions are too controversial so we can
have you here and going to my point and
Adam I understand where you're kind of
coming from but if I I'm interested to
see Rob if you could even look up you're
not going to see it what are the
percentage of FBI agents that are
left-leaning or democrat because where
are all the Republicans when FBI has
been doing all this dirt for all their
years what do we have two whistleblowers
that were like hey guys collusion and
small little whistle blows but the
majority of them are what they're all
left well they all work for Hillary they
all work with all these guys I'm very
very curious to see how many of them are
actually how many they're letting in
that actually go to the right yeah
because I'm not senior actually you I
think you made a really good point about
um
just sort of the timeliness of where
we're at would you would you agree that
2020 2021 with the election with kovid
with lockdowns with mandates with uh gen
Z sort of being this is their first time
to vote all that kind of culminating
that that was the worst of the worst of
the worst what this cancel culture
meaning it can't get worse than it was
during covet right like in the in the
greater context like we're sort of
coming out of it we're seeing the
economy we're seeing just the the
pushback from whether it's it's musk and
Twitter and things being more open you
know less less people getting canceled
do you think we've seen the worst of it
is my question on the cancer culture
side all of that correct well okay so
here's here's the part that for me uh uh
I'll get comfortable with okay so if you
if you think about uh well school system
when we're talking about the number of
people teachers professors we talked
about this a couple podcasts ago where
they measured by the purely by the
dollar contribution School teachers this
is why I want everybody to consider
taking their kids out of private out of
public school and put them in public
school private schools and consider
homeschooling I recommend every parent
consider taking their kids out of public
schools and putting it in private school
or homeschooling if you can afford it
English teachers out of 100 teachers in
America 90 97 were Democrats three were
Republicans in public school uh Health
teachers in America out of 199 Democrats
one Republican Math and Science teachers
out of 100 based on contribution 87
Democrat 13 Republican that is a
monopoly it's not a 50 50. okay private
private schools are not 80 Republican 70
Republican or 60 percent of a republican
there's still 60 percent Democrat
because most teachers are not making
enough money where their policies would
be policies to vote on maybe on one side
sixty percent of teachers in private
school are still Democrats but it's a
little bit more of a balanced situation
so where am I going to answer your
question here here's my answer to your
question
what's happening is
for 15 years these social media
companies were all owned by the left yep
yep for 15 years so guess what when Alex
Jones got canceled the next day a
hundred people canceled them why because
they're all on the same page it's one
phone call hey Facebook hey Google hey
YouTube PayPal hey this is
the next step we interviewed him it was
9 11 by the way when I interviewed them
in Austin I want to say this was four or
five years ago 2019 maybe 2018 I don't
know the exact year when we sat down and
we interviewed Alex Jones the day after
he got canceled we were we were with him
this guy gets canceled so now does he
say crazy things of course he does does
he get himself in trouble of course he
does but today today a guy like that
saying something they have to be a
little bit more methodical to cancel
everybody because Elon Musk now here's
what we need more of we need one or two
more to be bought look at what Spotify
did the best thing with Spotify you guys
have no idea how big of a role Spotify
played a year ago with Joe Rogan when
everybody was saying cancel cancel Joe
Rogan with a Spotify a company out of
Sweden Sweden yeah and they said yeah no
we're not going to cancel it I'm doing
it what do you mean we're not going to
cancel them 2018 was the Alex Jones
interview September 13th the video went
out but the interview was on 9 11. yeah
I'm not canceling them you're not
canceling no we're not going to cancel
Joe Rogan so everybody was hoping if
if Spotify I cannot tell you guys how
big of a role Spotify played in the
concept of cancel culture if Spotify
would have said no we are going to
cancel Joe Rogan let me tell you
massively problematic for a lot of
people in America if Spotify would have
canceled Joe
Joe now gets every everybody else is now
saying damn the guy from Sweden is also
defending what they're doing here in the
U.S then we had a problem Spotify helped
cancel culture in America more than
Americans even know so shout out to is
it Daniel Eck the founder and the CEO of
Spotify whatever you're doing out there
building your platform no when's the
last time you heard about somebody
getting canceled on Spotify I haven't
when's the last time you heard somebody
getting their shows turned taken down on
Spotify no one even talks about Spotify
they're very Everybody Talks Rumble but
Rumble is a conservative platform
Spotify has left right metal those who
hate Republicans those who can't stand
capitalism and they're totally okay with
it I'm telling you one of the most
important companies on cancel culture
the last 12 months was Spotify thank God
they get very little credit for what
they do and if you look at Northern
Europe and we could digress on this but
I will and I won't is first of all you
have Spotify that's up there segment we
have Finland and Sweden where there's
some very different views about covid
and masks and vaccine nation and so
northern Europe has been an anchor of
assistance
fighting against us I have a question
I'd like to ask for you is you know
because I'm starting to see it here in
America where that the Asian Community
is not being treated as one of the
ethnic minorities and they are being
treated as quasi-conservative Yale
University had a big lawsuit about how
they were discriminating heavily against
Asian students so that they could have
more numbers of other minorities that
would come in and get federal grants so
they were bringing minorities admitting
him into Yale and after Biden won the
election this is the federal government
dropped the Sue and so I'm hearing a lot
about that what are you seeing obviously
you saw it firsthand with the FBI are
you seeing this in other areas where you
know you know Asians coming to this
country are being treated as well you
know it's harder to turn you into a
lifelong Democrat you're more likely to
be conservative and so we're taking
steps have you seen that since you've
been here yeah I think I heard that very
often I talk about I talk about the
cancer culture and the danger of it and
talk about the oppression that real
oppression is happening in China and
North Korea or Iran and they say that
like how do you know about oppression
because you are a white passing person
wow yeah so it's interesting like they
view now Asians as white because we are
also making a lot of money I think who
is saying this to you this I mean like
college students
they listen as a white guy
I don't think that Asians I've never
been like look at those Asians over
there oh those white people they they're
privileged it's just it so this isn't
adding up to me we'll talk about the
admissions group but let me just go to
the story that validates what she's
saying I I think I understand what
you're saying fully that physically
you're like yeah you're not you're not a
white guy white lady categorically they
think there is such thing against Asian
privilege the the privileged part that
they see white privilege and Asian
privilege that being a real thing let me
just read the story yeah so most
Americans think college admissions
should not consider race okay 62 of
Americans are say race and ethnicity
should not be considered at all in
college admissions according to a new
Reuters poll okay the public opinion
found uh that 73 of Republicans and 46
percent of Democrats said they were
against race conscious admissions or
affirmative action which is a practice
used by colleges and universities to
boost racial diversity with within their
student bodies again 73 percent of
Republicans say no I don't want to know
about the race I just want to know who's
the best student but 46 percent of
Democrats say meaning 54 saying no we
have to consider what race it is before
you get into college grades don't matter
your race does right that's what they're
saying 67 percent of white respondents
said they were against considering race
out on admissions compared to 52 percent
of minority respondents the conservative
leading U.S Supreme Court will issue
ruling this spring in cases questioning
the legality of race conscious
admissions practices at Harvard and
University of North Carolina the group
behind the lawsuit student of uh for
Fair admission says that the UNC
discriminations discriminates against
white and Asian American applicants and
Harvard discriminates against Asian
American applicants that was the
question Tom was asking do you think we
should consider race when it comes down
to going to universities I think that's
what I'm like I was writing in my book
that's like the tactics they use to
divide people and punish people for
Collective gears like they're saying
like oh Adam is white therefore his
ancestors were privileged people and now
he should be guilty right
I think that tactic is like a very North
Korean tactic like my great-grandfather
was a landowner so they were saying when
I was born my genetics is oppressive my
blood is Tainted therefore I can never
be forgiven even though that was not my
choice to on the land
Now in America we punished like I have a
son who's a half white he's so screwed
he's supposed to be guilty about a
privilege they have white and Asian yeah
I mean he's double guilty teleporting to
uh according to these guys yeah and
actually based on the just merits the
competence it says just Asians should be
at Harvard more than 70 percent of them
should be Asians if you're gonna let
them in buy the Merit and exam score but
then Harvard only accepts 11 point
something percent each year because they
have like the quora race quora
so actually the rear victims about
foreign
so hard and that's how they get punished
for it
so I think this is one of the things
that I see we become like North Korea we
do not value the Merit and competence
and somehow accepting dividing People
based on what they are not responsible
for which is a collective gift
I think you you hit the the nail on the
head there is that more than anything in
America not only we are democracy but we
are a meritocracy you talked about Merit
why are Asians overwhelmingly being
considered or admitted to Harvard is
because they [__] kick ass in school
how about that like if you look at
certain ethnicities okay I'm Jewish if
you look at income in America you can
fact check this I don't know I want to
say Asians and Jews are leading the list
yeah okay also Indians to a certain
extent as well and why is that because
they come from a culture that that
values hard work education and there's a
culture and the tight-knit family family
values and being raised uh in a
two-parent household and there's a
multitude of reasons why these types of
people succeed now uh from what I know
about my Jewish mother they do they're a
lot more like kissy Huggy Huggy than a
lot of my Asian friends I've had
conversations with my Asian friends
they're they're more bowing and all that
but the family values and the the
close-knit value and the emphasis on
education is tantamount to these types
of families and no wonder there's going
to be success like like the tiger mom uh
you know story about all that is like
they demand that you do your work like
is anyone going to be shocked that Pat's
kids are going to be are going to do
well and successful why because it's a
meritocracy even in his house did you
read did you shoot your shots did you
just play outside today did you do all
your work if you did that then you can
go play video games and have fun with
your friends but there's accountability
there and that's exactly what's going on
in Asian households and a lot of times
in Jewish households and you know for
other people in America that don't have
that type of accountability
when they don't when they're not having
accessible let me ask you and by the way
yeah
Tico Dylan Center Brooklyn when one day
you guys watch it the pressure isn't on
you one of you guys is gonna do
something big we'll see which one
anyways let's go over here all right so
uh uh uh going back so question basic
question and run a poll for this Rob so
we can see what the audience is saying
should it's a very basic question yes or
no all of us should American colleges
consider race when accepting
applications Adam
uh I think
race should not be on a top 10 list okay
Vinnie no I I 100 say no Tom no no okay
now of course it's going to be no for
mind you know to to and by the way
here's what's crazy I should say yes
do you know why because if my kids
applying they say they're from Iran it's
like hey we need to hit our numbers for
Iran yeah
Jack and pick and choose one of them I
can say Armenian I can say Syria Syrian
listen there's only two of us in America
future minimums you know but yeah
percent right huh you get the emea
percent Europe Middle East Africa we
need some of that check listen look at
who who is the current up-and-coming
superstar in the NBA that's 23 years old
okay how high does he jump
but he's a great player yes and nobody
should care what skin color he is he
just kicks out he's not even from
America by the way he's from uh you know
you're where's he from Slovenia Slovenia
right on what he does anyways okay so
that's that part with this I'm gonna go
to within the education uh uh realm of
stories I kind of want to talk to you on
uh uh a curriculum having to do with
sexuality so if you can prepare this
video Rob English teacher sexuality
curriculum showing kids penis pics
ejaculation video has school approval
issues okay so let's kind of take a look
at this one here this just came out a
couple days ago kind of weird uh
obviously Al bernaccio an English
teacher at friends central school a
private school in Pennsylvania like I
told you most private school doesn't
mean they're all Republicans if it's
private school okay
has been involved in schools sexuality
curriculum from Nursery to 12th grade
vernacio revealed that he showed
close-up photos of genitalia and a video
of a woman ejaculating in option
optional sexuality class to desensitize
children
and teach them about the broad range of
what is out there students in 11th and
12th grade were exposed to these graphic
lessons but had the option to opt out
and parents had to sign off on
enrollments the students stood by
vernacio stating that he is a nationally
renowned and highly respected educator
or Nacho's goal is to provide
age-appropriate Transformer
transformative
sexuality education for all the students
he's also commented that every child is
a sexual being can you play that let him
just watch his motivational video by
this guy just watch this for a second
at my school I'm responsible for the
sexuality education of all of our
students from our youngest students who
are three years old in Nursery School
up through our 12th graders who are
turning 18 and getting ready to leave
High School
that's a huge range but every single one
of those kids is a sexual being
they have been since birth
and at every age and Stage we can offer
them age-appropriate transformative
sexuality education
I'm only a small part of the village
that supports them as they grow
it's not enough that I teach them we
have to teach them
part of my message today is that we all
no matter what else we do in life need
to find a way to be sexuality Educators
for the kids in our lives
if we don't step up others will
and many of those others if we don't
step up please send Freedom the way we
do
one of the things we can do they don't
have freedom the way we do is how young
people have so many more options to
consider than simply whether they feel
like a boy or a girl I think Chris
Hansen's going to come out now straight
or bisexual
our understandings of both gender and
orientation rob you can't stop it at
this point you get the idea on what's
going on here so I can play more and
read more about this article time as a
parent of uh two daughters okay one is
in high school and one's in uh fifth
grade or fourth grade secretary in just
sixth grade how how do you feel about
what uh this teacher is doing and
whether we should be a little bit more
comfortable with this uh I think we
should be uncomfortable about it what
they are is they're evolving what's out
there to sexualize kids early
we have had sex education in school and
had you know films for girls and a lot
of things your body is changing and all
these things we've had these things in
America for 50 years and those have been
changing along with uh to include things
about STDs and things like that and then
leaving it to the parents to conduct you
know the rest of the you know
discussions you have that's a joke you
have the talk with your boys and that's
it and I'm kind of alarmed when I listen
to this between the lines there children
have more choices so what they're doing
is they're putting ideas in kids heads
about what their sexual choices are
according to the new list that he has
and is that list now going to be 21
items long you know five years from now
I don't know but I think this parents
and schools have done a good job up to
this point and you have basically the
sexual the the agenda is to
hypersexualize our kids and to introduce
things in there to get them more quickly
on that path this isn't about education
this is about indoctrination by the way
if anybody knows how to get a hold of
him whoever this teacher is Alvar nachio
I'm in contact with uh the gentleman of
Frank Rodriguez I want to say his name
is I play this video do you remember the
guy gaze against groomers yes if Alice
had Alice or Al if Al has this much
conviction in his beliefs Frank would be
more than happy to have a conversation
with you because I asked Frank if he's
open to me bringing other people yeah to
you give your argument let him give his
argument to talk about why you're
grooming kids and by the way what is it
with these teachers who are so obsessed
with teaching kids on sexuality why do
they all look the same I don't know one
more points one more Point yeah ten
years ago a female teacher that showed
pictures of her breasts to a male
student It ultimately ended up in Affair
she's doing time yeah this guy
this guy is she really doing time yeah
go back and look at it's pretty wild you
know I mean what oh you were grooming
young boys yeah okay all right Lolita I
mean I have a child right it's it's a
heartbreaking that it's my child that we
are letting other like schools do this
like he's in North Korea you know it's
not your child the school's gonna shape
the child and
not just like
I I mean children should be children
like I don't I in North Korea we did not
have any sex education so maybe some of
it when you're ready is fine
but two three from three years old I
think this is a new thing they are going
for their life is going for is they're
called map the minor attracted person
it's not a pedophile anymore if you're
attracted child you're not a pedophile
you're like like minor attractive person
they're trying to normalize this concept
that it's okay to be attracted to a
toddler it just
beyond evil and beyond disgusting and
like
I don't know like it's
yeah something's going on it's it's a
horrible nowadays the gender is a
construct right you said something you
say if you can unpack this you said uh
in North Korea do do they look at North
Korea that if you have a kid it's the
country's kids is that kind of how they
view it it's a collective it's in ours
our people it's not yours of course not
we cannot say I you know there's no I
wow yeah like there are people you can
say I feel this no so I like water now
you really like water we like kimchi we
like barbecue
very important to understand you can't
even use the word I I am happy I want to
go to the park today so what is it just
me we are happy we want to go to the
park dude yes that's very bizarre oh
dude and the Loyalty leads to individual
yeah competition among individuals
winners and losers oh we can't have that
in communism yeah I saw a documentary
I'm pretty sure you've heard about you
are you uh although falls on Netflix
clicks or something just the the pure
the sheer like the not the brainwash but
the the devotion I forgot who was in
charge but this uh American doctor went
there and all these blind like all these
people that had basic cataract they're
all blind he cured like I don't know how
many hundreds or thousands and the first
thing they did when their eyes were open
they went to the Supreme Leader's a
picture and were bowing and kissing and
crying it's not like she just said it's
not about it was and like if you didn't
show that I'm pretty sure you got
punished for but it was so like you just
you're seeing for the first time some of
them in their lives and they didn't want
to talk to any they were they were just
they saw the picture of him and they
went and they bowed and they cried and
they gave him all the all it was all him
well well I have a question
we will give you our answer well yeah
you collect them yeah because we're on
the topic of the sexualization of kids
and and all that
um I'm just wondering as parents
it doesn't seem to be a black and white
thing you can't talk about it you can't
talk about it at this age you can do it
at this age you can't do it so you know
there's a big difference I think between
you know K through six versus you know
High School right so by the way you were
absolutely right this guy looks like a
complete creep right now he reminds me
of the the principal in uh Billy Madison
the revolting blob if you want to pull
up his picture
it's uncannon how this guy is just that
weird but I was having a conversation
with my nephew yesterday who's 10 years
old and uh I I have an active role in
his life as like his Uncle like you know
he slept over this weekend like that's
my guy and we're playing football
playing baseball so I I have a moment
with him yesterday and I said so you
know how's school going all that it goes
so who are your closest friends talk to
me about uh the guys and you know the
homies he's like well you know this guy
this guy to go well and he any girls
that you think are pretty and he's like
wow don't ask me about that you know I'm
like well what you got and he's like
well there's there's two there's two I'm
like all right my guy you know
and we started having this conversation
and very nonchalantly he's like well you
know there's a couple kids in my class
that are gay and you know I'm just uh
but I do my things what what does that
mean he goes yeah they're they're gay
and I doesn't say the word yeah and keep
in mind he's 10 years old he's in fourth
grade I've never discussed this with him
in his life about this yeah
and I go what does that mean he goes
don't play dumb with me 10 years old
come on Adam and I go what are your
thoughts on that he goes well you know
they can do what they want and I think
we've known this for some time 10 years
old wow he's smart and I go well you
know you you like girls right he's like
yeah I like the girls but and I go just
treat them nice there's nothing wrong
with them but just know that that's
that's their thing that's not your thing
but the point is this
I had no idea he even knew that word I
had no idea that he even understood what
that meant so that was like a a moment
for me where I was like holy crap my
nephew the kid that I helped raise I had
no idea that these are conversations I
said who taught you about they goes oh
my friends we talk about it so the kids
know about this stuff is what I was what
I was saying that podcast uncle uncle
Adam I saw it on the podcast for the
nice lady who thought uh yeah yeah you
were here
not that there's anything wrong there's
nothing wrong with g-a-y Pat it's funny
Pat's son Dylan the other day I was like
um I was like so Dylan what's up how are
you what's up with the girls like yeah
what's her name uh the girl that he's
dating he's like yeah whatever just
nonchalant and then just yesterday he's
like Benny uh Vinnie I was like yeah
this is Dylan do you love do you love
Kelly I go what are you what are you
talking about he's like I mean Kelly you
like you love Kelly I'm like yeah but
where are you going to and then five
minutes later Santa's like hey Vinnie do
you like that girl over there this girl
because she acted with you I'm like I I
love the they're asking questions but
then
it's none of my business to even get to
any depth conversation with kids neither
should teachers neither should anybody
that's up to the parents to do whatever
and sex said when I was a kid Tom I'm
pretty sure you had the same thing the
only sex education we had it was just
like a black and white of the inside of
the girl they showed the guy they were
like yeah and I didn't know any details
and your parents had to sign a form or
you could opt out you talked about acne
and it talked about hormones it was very
basic it was like two days so okay we've
we've seen the basics the health class
next but but what I wanted to understand
was at what age is are these
conversations appropriate because what
I'm assuming is that they're happening
regardless if you want to step in as a
parent and have these conversations and
I've said this before nothing would have
been more Awkward to me than my dad
being like hey you know you got a dick
down there son whoa heavy you want to
have this conversation with you Dad yeah
very early I'm five years old you've
heard me tell the story yeah your dad no
no I did with kids with the kids okay
smart yeah we're in the shower I said
that's your dangling
that's yours this is mine I said uh
that's the greatest toy God ever gave
you okay if only you get to play with
that nobody gets to play with that one
day a woman you'll find will help you
play with that but till then you're
gonna play with that by yourself okay
and the looks on their faces when they
looked at me was very awkward Jennifer
ran out very quickly but they understood
and by the way these things if you don't
talk about these things with your kids
man and say hey there's only three
people you can keep secrets with us at
the house we can have secrets together
as a family you don't go out there and
somebody in school says hey this is our
secret no such thing if he gives you a
video game this or that there is no sin
we as a family we can have those types
of things later on when you're married
with you and your wife you guys gonna
have your own Secrets till then
there's only a couple people you can
have secrets anyway there's a whole uh
things you can do there go ahead no no
should the school have in this I'm
talking about this topic yeah what role
should the school have because you had
this talk and you even used the word
awkward I think listen yeah
this guy's showing porn to kids yeah
that's not sex said That's not healthy
what he's doing is showing a woman
please herself sexually that's not hey
guys let me show you how I please myself
look how great it feels this is how you
do it that's not success that's porn
Okay so and unless if they want to make
porn legal in schools that's a different
story a teacher shouldn't be going out
there showing these types of things
teachers responsibility is here's the
dangling
here's a you know vagina here's what you
do with the condom here's why you do it
you know do not participate in
unprotected sex do not participate in
sex try to hold off as long as you can
it's important if you make this decision
maybe talk to your parents about this
your faith your whatever commitments it
is you have to take it from that angle
not from the angle of so this is what uh
lesbians are this is what gays are this
is what trans is this is what this is
this is what bias and it's normal some
people are like that you're putting that
thought in their head you're putting
their thought you know you know the
Pygmalion Theory or you know the
Pygmalion Theory you know the theory of
if I tell you Adam
if I constantly point out something in
you and I say that that whole concept
about low class Inc low low income
middle income upper class low-income
families that raise kids they say 600
000 words from 0 to 18 that are a
rejection word from 0 to 18. this isn't
a book called the Genius in all of us so
low income families they reject their
kids 600 000 times from zero to 18.
Middle income is a hundred thousand
times rejection upper class parents is a
hundred times affirming you can do it if
you pull it off you can do it if you
work hard for it you can do it if you do
it like the kids four kids I said one of
them of course all of them can be
successful and couple them may not do
anything with their lives but the
choices on who on them the the the word
that you put in still in my my head that
works if somebody says like I told
Vinnie I said Vinnie I think you're
super talented I think you're super
capable the other day I told Vinnie he
looks like a Colin Farrell to me you
know Jennifer and I were we're talking
like this guy looks like Colin Farrell
and Robert Downey Jr and you know
sometimes you say this and you say it
privately people are like oh he's just
trying to make me feel good and he say
publicly and it's real I don't say to
say it guess what Vinnie is now going to
walk away and say wow this guy really
believes in me but if I say to Vinnie
Vinnie if you if you want to be bi it's
totally cool yeah but if you want to be
trans maybe you're trans and you don't
know it maybe you ought to consider that
you know some people are yeah show that
picture by the way of uh Vinnie this has
been oh wow last week this has been last
week why would you do that well yes look
why would you do that
if I if I stick my hair back okay
[Laughter]
you and Adam could date it's okay
to me that's my biggest concern when you
say something like that to my to my kids
or the people around me I'm very
uncomfortable with certain words words
have so much power you have to be
careful with that anyways let's go to
the next story you can't date Adam no no
because you know he's a you know yeah
j-o-o yeah exactly Drew
but can I make one last point I know we
want to move on and this is because only
how we have parents here and I think
this is important
you talked about when back in my day
with the class we talked it was a black
and white picture
one thing that we have to remember is
the internet didn't exist in the 90s
when we were growing up you you look at
the the stats and kids are exposed to
porn as early as 10 years old at this
point on the internet I think the
average age is 12 years old we were
lucky if we found a Playboy when we were
12 years old it was like oh my God what
is this so somebody's dad had one under
the bed exactly sure it was might have
been the biz doc I don't know but not at
our house but my question is this is
these conversations are gonna are are
greatly exacerbated and it's having
happening so much quicker because kids
are online every kid has their uh iPad
that they just go in their room with at
the end of the night that didn't exist
20 years ago 10 years ago for that
matter so that has to be a major concern
for parents right there is that's where
they're going to be exposed to it online
you make a good point and basically what
it says is every generation will have
its challenges for with parents you know
what do you listen to on the radio what
are you watching on TV there what are
you you know running at the video store
what do you watch on the internet and
with each generation of parents the
technology is there so parents have to
moderate what they do when they do it my
parents had a conversation with me about
hey nobody touches you and it's not
anybody's little secret because that was
a known technique that Predators would
use to intimidate kids or coerce them
I'll hurt your sister if you tell
anything this is our secret so my
parents alerted me said nobody touches
you and anybody says this boom and they
did that at it at you know I think I was
like you know seven eight years old
started going public school but Kim and
I have had conversations earlier with
Bailey and Brooke because of exactly you
say because of the technology that's
around that just underlines the
responsibility of parents not the
obligation of an of a socially you know
indoctrinated school and that's my
that's my two cents okay all right
sounds good so here let's transition to
the next story so uh you know one of the
things Andrew Tate's been gone now for a
few months for a couple months and one
of the things he would be very proud of
there's somebody else they're trying to
replace him Don Lemon Don lemon's been
uh wow working very hard to beat a new
Andrew
it's important to see this you know when
you watch this clip on what he said the
other day by the way when he said this I
retweeted this yesterday and I said it's
obvious I'm telling you right now I'm
convinced Don Lemon is obsessed and in
love with and rotate and watches
non-stop I think videos and clips of the
only reason you would say something like
this is because you watch certain clips
of go ahead and play this clip real
quick see what he said he got in trouble
for it all the talk about age makes me
uncomfortable I think that I think it's
the wrong road to go down well Jesus
people you know politicians or something
and not in their Prime Nikki Haley isn't
in their Prime sorry when a woman is
considered being a gay girl when he's at
30s and maybe 40s that's not according
to me fighting for what it depends I
mean it's just like Prime if you look it
up it'll say if you look if you Google
it'll say 20s 30s and 40s
I'm not saying I agree with that so I
think she has to be careful about saying
that you know politicians aren't in
their Prime are you talking about Prime
for like child preparing or are you
talking about
the facts or Google it everybody at home
here we go I'm just saying Nikki Haley
should be careful about saying that
politicians are not in their Prime and
they need to be in their primary
Services by the way if that was Whoopi
Goldberg on his left at this five
seconds ago in this clip he would have
been shot on camera but hey did you
notice that for first two things first
he goes I don't want to go down that
road you know what he did he went down
that road
but what do you see like this is his
sassiness he's like he's that was him
just show that's how dude that's how he
actually feels at the same token he's a
hardcore leftist that's throwing the jab
to let people know but he's gonna be
running here's a question though yeah is
he truly a hardcore leftist or has he
been spending too much time with
hardcore left his words have power and
phones has power Tom and I Tom shared a
clip the other day with me I'm going to
show you guys here in a second what is
your reaction uh uh yomi when you hear
he says what he says that Nikki Haley is
Pastor Prime while Hillary Clinton's in
her 70s thinking about running while
Kamala Harris is older than Nikki Haley
what do you think about my hear that
comment he makes I think he he's just
desperate trying to make a point that
why she's not qualifying for the job
right but I mean it's it's
interesting to see him getting pushed
back on CNN I don't think they ever push
it back anybody who's Democrat right so
maybe CNN is trying new thing I don't
know well apparently he's suspended he
gave an apology to CNN and his
colleagues from Miami
um however he never apologize to Nikki
Haley he's in Miami right now if people
with his husband yeah and go ahead so
yeah well
100 she's gay oh yeah not Adam that's
not my boyfriend yeah no no no anymore
um
so here's what's happened you ever see
like uh one of those like scary movies
and they're like where is it coming from
and it's like the calls coming from
inside the house yeah that's exactly
what's Happening Here on their their
Morning Show two women in their 40s
nonetheless yeah and he's like oh you
old broads yeah like wow what just
happened here the call just came from
inside the studio so what he's
conflating and this is just clearly he
just Googled uh Prime he's conflating
two things a woman's sexual market value
yes with her actual market value and
there's two completely separate things
he's he's correct that a woman's sexual
market value is let's just say 40 and
Below what does that mean sexual market
value is when most men are attracted to
women it's usually in their
mid-20s give or take that's a sexual
market value okay whereas a man reaches
his sexual market value typically in his
late 30s typically so women their uh
Beauty objects where men are success
objects that's that's what comes down to
the sexual market value what he's
conflating again is sexual market value
with market value you could be a hell of
a governor or a businesswoman or an
entrepreneur or anything well into your
40s 50s 60s and when whether you like
Hillary Clinton or not she was a capable
politician let's just put it at that so
Nikki Haley who's in her 50s market
value is is
arguably at its highest it's ever been
whereas her sexual market value might
not be that high right now so I think
Don Lemon is just trying to make a point
and his foot is so far in his freaking
mouth right now that he's just like ah
vacation Miami by I'm out here's what I
want you to watch I want you to watch
this this is the old Don Lemon when he
first got into media and not not first
this is this is not that old just so you
guys know this is like five ten years
ago but listen to how Don Lemon spoke
just 10 years ago so the old I think
this is the real yeah because black
people if you really want to fix the
problem here's just five things that you
should think about doing here's number
five and if if this doesn't apply to you
if you're not doing this then it doesn't
apply to you I'm not talking about you
here's number five pull up your pants
walking around with your ass and your
underwear showing is not okay in fact it
comes from prison when they take away
belts from The Prisoner so that they
can't make a weapon and then it evolved
into which role a prisoner would have
during male on male Prison Sex the one
with the really low pants is a
submissive one
you get my point
number four now is the n-word
by promoting the use of that word when
it's not germane to the conversation
have you ever considered that you may
just be perpetuating The Stereotype the
master intended acting like a [__] now
number three Jesus respect where you
live
start small by not dropping trash
littering in your own communities I've
lived in several predominantly white
neighborhoods in my life I rarely if
ever witness people littering I live in
Harlem now it's an historically black
neighborhood every single day I see
adults and children dropping their trash
on the ground when a garbage can is just
feet away
just being honest here number two finish
school you want to break the cycle of
poverty stop telling kids are acting
white because they go to school or they
speak proper English a high school
dropout makes on average nineteen
thousand dollars a year a heist a high
school graduate makes twenty eight
thousand dollars a year a college
graduate makes fifty one thousand
dollars a year over the course of a
career a college grad will make nearly a
million dollars more than a high school
graduate that's a lot of money
and number one and probably the most
important just because you can have a
baby it doesn't mean you should
especially without planning for one or
getting married first more than 72
percent of children in the
African-American Community imagine this
is the limit yeah listen absent fathers
no keep playing the studies show that
lack of a male role model is an Express
train right to prison and the cycle
continues
could I ask you a question about what
changes my question I think this is not
I agree with that what happened by the
way look at her face
are you shocked or what she's a trump
yeah
who that actually does sound like is a
lot very reminiscent of Thomas Soul like
that that's the type of message you
would hear from a black conservative
like a Thomas soul type and it just you
never hear him talk like that anymore
trick bet David well yeah but here's
here's my question to you guys though
the other grade what makes you change
what makes someone like that without
your good voice yes I see the logo that
it's CNN which I don't even give a damn
at that point how does how does he
change or what changes in the network
that he has to turn into this person do
I mean what I I don't know what your
politics yeah the answer the answer is
what yonmi said Donald it was Trump I
thought it was no but but here's the
Obama Trump thing yeah [__] people's
heads up I agree well you think but I
mean dude you still have a producer like
think about this CNN let him say
something like this there is no way in
hell CNN is letting Don Lemon say this
type of [__] what year was that I have
no idea 2013. who was President 2013.
Obama Obama under the Obama
Administration it was okay to be cool no
it was just normal it was it was is it
okay to call out the nonsense by the way
it was and then with Obama's 2013 after
he's reelected correct so in the middle
of Obama about you as a pundit opinion
not a journalist a a pundit or giving
your opinion on what black people should
do to clean up their life much like we
talked about how Asians and Jews and
Indians what they do in the family
culture okay but once Trump hit the
scene it no longer became a hey this is
what you need to do to help your life
this is not what you do for Success pick
up your pants go to school none of that
it was just [__] Trump okay and that's
where this whole narrative basically
veered off course
that was a great point though that was
so funny by the way so you just you just
have to think about this you become who
you hang around with words have power
if you're around people that are
influencing you to think like a victim
you will if you're around people that
will tell you stop feeling sorry for
yourself you're either eventually gonna
hate them and go find people who feel
sorry for themselves or you're going to
be like you know what stop feeling sorry
for yourself man life is a lot harder
other places right so this message here
tells you the difference between
thinking for yourself and then all of a
sudden getting into the mainstream media
and those guys trying to control you and
tell you what you have to think in a
call hey you guys better say this hey
you guys better say that hey you guys
better say this and then boom it turns
into Don Lemon having a pilot what are
the likelihood he's going to get fired
he's on suspension right now I don't
think he's in the info there's no way
just as we came on the air here this
morning it was announced that he will be
reinstated later this week after he
undergoes a special training and they
didn't say what that was it's just
special training and so uh yeah it's
called Hustlers University yeah
but by the way we talked to the initial
conversation we had the on the episode
was is cancel culture over not yeah is
is this a form of cancel culture that he
can't even State like should he have
been suspended for this I I don't think
so listen
yeah but dude we're just wrong
if this was Fox he would have been fired
there's no take a time no he would have
had a parade no no they said if he said
if that if he offended women like that
on on a conservative he's gone the left
I think that's this no but my point is
the only thing I've never said this on
Fox the women would have been like yeah
for sure like they would have no I don't
think so what I'm saying is the cancer
you think Fox would have been more
sympathetic to what he had to say they
would have not liked what he said you're
hitting me the reaction of what a lot of
the women first of all you have to what
did Fox deal with just a few years ago
with Megan Kelly yeah
but Bill O'Reilly so so what I'm saying
my point my point being it's not to kill
you off bad is the left is way more well
like you could they they look out for
each other bro the left takes care of
their own I'm not gonna say that either
because CNN also fired the uh uh Chris
Cuomo they fired uh who's the uh other
person they fired
it's a time where you know what they
opened it up to though guess what they
opened it up to if you say something
like that on a podcast what happens to
you you keep continuing if you say
something like that they're just opening
it up for people by the way if he made a
fool out of himself you can make a fool
out of yourself on a podcast you can
make a fool out of yourself on a uh uh
YouTube show that you're on many have
many will many will continue it's part
of what happens you're gonna get caught
nobody's undefeated in the boxing ring
except for who Floyd Mayweather Floyd
Mayweather and Marciano I think was also
undefeated I don't know if he lost or
not so for the most part you're gonna
get caught Ali lost six times you're not
going to get into a debate and be
undefeated in debates sometimes you're
gonna get caught and this time he got
caught but as crazy as it sounds if CNN
wants to kind of go in the direction of
recreating themselves they have to show
how they handle situations like this
to allow a person to screw up and then
come back versus hey we're still walking
on excels here so I'm not telling you
they should fire them or not fire them
CNN is right now dealing with identity
crisis people go through this men go
through it when they say well you're a
midlife crisis you know they go by
motorcycle and get a tattoo on their
neck this typically happens at 45 years
old right no I'm telling you you think
I'm kidding with you they get it done
with girls go through midlife crisis
they do stuff and then they get a tattoo
on their butt like on their lower back
which is different story everybody goes
through a different kind of midlife
crisis some people start doing steroids
to be buffer bigger stronger we all have
insecurities that we're trying to stay
young forever this is not an abnormal
thing we're all normal going through
these things
here these guys are
um Danza in an organization right now
that's trying to recreate themselves and
quite frankly dance in the middle right
now saying ah [__] what do I do to make
these guys happy you know he's probably
there in Miami saying listen babe if
they fire me he's talking to his
boyfriend if they fire me we got to
figure out what to do we got some money
here but maybe I'll go start a podcast
FYI transitioning from TV to podcast
isn't as easy as they think it is yeah
we learned that with Chris when you're
on TV they give you a script when you
got a podcast man you better try to keep
attention for a couple hours it ain't
that easy to do so right well he went
off script here and they should have
written well can I just say one thing as
someone who's never messed up on a
podcast I've never been called naive
I've never been called an idiot I've
never been called to Soy boy I
definitely have never had any pushback
whatsoever there's zero negative
comments out about me zero amazing that
I've never had an issue but no it never
happened once never happened thanks Tom
it's actually 100 but I think it would
be a very
horrible disservice to cancel download
lemon for this situation you screwed up
like by definition you know you
conflated what sexual market value was
with market value CNN has an opportunity
here to basically say hey we are not the
the Arbiters of cancel culture you know
take a day off go ahead we'll see you
back give them me a culpa when you get
back uh on on TV and learn from it and
that's I think what the definition of
cancer culture should not be is like
everyone screws up people are right
people are wrong there's different
opinions there's all that that's the
whole premise of America is the to be
able to have that debate and when you
screw up like yo my bad I'll do better
yeah and that's what I think he needs to
do final thoughts you and me on this
before we move forward is there a
message you have for our friend Don
Lemon
yeah I think that's what I was writing
in my book was like we have right to be
wrong
you know we we should have a culture of
like Mercy in North Korea you make one
mistake you get executed and in America
currently you lose your job livelihood
reputation and dignity but eventually if
you're pushing this direction you can
end up like North Korea so now we're in
somewhere in the middle we can push
backwards where we have a culture of
mercy and let people make a mistake and
correct it so yeah I don't think he
should ever get fired for this that's so
stupid I mean he's no matter what he has
a talent right he's a good presenter so
but he said sorry so you should come
back
and he's very
yeah man like I wonder when's the last
time he watched himself from 10 years
ago probably no way no way but but you
know like I I was watching a clip this
morning I sent it to Mario I can't play
because of Music plays in there it's an
incredible speech
that uh Robert Downey Jr gives he's up
there accepting a award and he says I
brought Mel Gibson here to uh with me
while I'm accepting this award he says
there's a reason why I brought Mel
Gibson him when I was going through my
mess Mel called me and we were speaking
and he says listen man whatever you do
go find your faith but it's got to be
your fate I don't care what it is but go
find your faith he says I respected the
fact that he told me to go find my faith
and I did and he says so then there's a
movie that while nobody's accepting me I
don't have any money I don't know how to
pay rent I have a hard time dropping
alcohol I have a hard time dropping
anything Mel gives me a role that he was
supposed to take but he gave it to me he
called me says this is for you he says
that itself helped me so much because it
allowed me to pay my bills during this
time and I did that and then next thing
you know my career takes off and I told
Mel how can I pay it back to you and you
know what Mel said when the next Robert
Downey Jr is going through this do it
for them again okay because somebody did
it for me you don't hear these types of
stories about Mel Gibson right about
about people the point I'm trying to
make is even a Robert Downey Jr had to
go back and watch some of his old clips
to say dude look how great you are and
how great you can be you know sometimes
athletes go through it you got to watch
old tape of 10 years ago five years ago
highlights I think Don lemon's got to go
watch that clip and say dude yeah look
at you
fire is viral video this
this outside of this
is that clip that got 3.3 million views
on Twitter if you go to it look at that
3.3 million views this was just posted
let's see when it was posted by the way
it was posted few days ago it's got It's
got I'm sorry 8.6 million views it's
what it's got why do you think Don this
has 8.6 million views no one's taking
shots at you no one's saying anything to
you no one's reacting to this video it's
only content of you speaking and there's
nine million people that are interested
of what you had to say 10 years ago you
may want to play this and watch this
while you're on vacation in Miami
anyways so great Point sometimes you got
to go back and get that source of
inspiration where the fire came from
instead of hey let me just kind of go
out there and do
what I'm doing here so can we can we
talk about
what's going on with Russia and Ukraine
and all the things that's going on
obviously President Biden pays the
surprise visit to uh Ukraine just uh I
think it was two days ago or maybe even
yesterday but I think it's yesterday he
pays a visit uh president arrives in
Kiev Ukraine and surprise visit to meet
the president uh zielinski and to
announce additional half a billion
dollars in U.S assistance ahead of one
of one year anniversary of Russia as a
nation of the country the new Aid
package includes artillery ammunition
anti-armor systems and air surveillance
Radars but no new Advanced weapons Biden
stated that this visit was to reaffirm
our unwavering and unflagging
commitment to Ukraine's democracy
sovereignty and territorial integrity
and to share that the U.S will announce
additional sanctions against Elites and
companies backing Russia's War Machine
Biden's visit to Ukraine comes at Russia
as Russia is expected to ramp up its
offensive once again and Ukraine
officials warn of massive barrage of
missiles that Russia May launch on
February 24th here's an interesting
thing to be thinking about he did this
on President's Day and never visited
East Palestine
took him 10 days to even recognize the
events in East Palestine Kamala hasn't
gone
they're not talking about the issues
that's going on there 100 billion
dollars given to them all of this stuff
going on the other day I did the math on
how many total homeless people we have
in America check this out they say they
want to end homelessness okay do you
know the 100 billion dollars that we
gave to Ukraine okay if homelessness in
America is that big of an issue you can
clean it up there's 524 total homeless
people in America roughly a third of
that is in California okay
524. if you took that 100 billion
dollars each homeless person could get
170 000 if you divide it up now you
don't need to give it to them if we took
that money and we created a place for
them to go to live work shelter
different things and cleaned up those
streets what would happen to Safety in
those communities what would happen to
those things now I'm not somebody that's
endorsing us going and spending the next
100 billion dollars for you because
somebody's going to come down and say
well well now would you support this now
would you support this now no what I'm
saying to you is the constant spending
of the money that we have what if we
take that while we have the issues here
we're going to Kiev while people in East
Palestine are wondering what's going on
with their water you're going over there
so anyway so while that's taking place
China and Russia is getting close at the
same time China's coming out and saying
we're great allies and then
simultaneously why this is going on for
the first time since the 70s Russia
started loading nuclear missiles on
ships first something since the 70s
while this is going on okay and then
zelinski comes out and says if China
allies itself with Russia there will be
World War and I do think that China is
aware of that so having said that you
being from that part of the world what
are your thoughts on what's going on and
how risky it is what we're doing uh if
we could potentially create a world war
three what are your thoughts
yeah I think it's it's it's no brainer
like who suffers from the world like the
people you know the women people and
like Elders they suffer the most
and I think not only that actually I
live in New York City I fled like
Chicago because the day we had our first
interview I got robbed
by black women and it's okay anybody can
be tiffed there she was punching me into
my wallet even from my son who's in
Chicago yes that exact that after and
after thing I went for a while but the
thing is people weren't on the street
circle around me that I'm a I'm a racist
that was trying to call the cops on
these dips
yeah
so people are crazy in Chicago they just
lost Common Sense they're never gonna
defend anybody because of my skin color
I was not having a black skin colorway
and then it was so I mean I charged her
to she was prison and then apparently
there's a huge Revenge crime they come
out they bring the gun just shoot you
and I'm a public person they know where
I am so I had to fully describe and come
to New York
I go with my son take a Subway and it is
beyond dangerous the first thing that is
Korean women telling me don't go near
the tracks because this people
especially black people just push Asian
people this is the New York from Chicago
New York did you think it was safer in
New York
it's not but what shocked me was on
every corner in downtown yeah I mean in
New York they said like drugs in the
purple like a looking like candy
and my son thinks it's a lollipop they
are selling so he just keep asking me to
buy the lollipop for him
so so like the southern border is open
I mean I'm not safe Living in America
it's so funny like I was looking for
security and safety and freedom now I
didn't get the security and safety in
America
so our country is like this much of mass
and we are defending some other people's
security like what about American
Security I'm All American my son is
American and I fears I'm like I'm
literally risking my life every day
taking that Subway and we have to take
this opinion nobody can afford to have a
bodyguard and take a like drive or take
you around
I think that's why I'm so like baffled
like what is this
so how long how much longer are you
planning on staying in New York I can't
because of custody of my son I got you
you have to be in the same city yeah
yeah well have you spoken to him about
leaving New York
well his things are way safer than
Chicago at least it's like a little bit
more safer than Chicago so it's a
relative thing you know you don't get
shot and bullets run through you as much
as Chicago so
you wanna know something about you know
you guys want to know why I think all
this is happening why the borders open
why why China's flying balloons why
everything's going to share while
Russia's threatening getting out of the
start treating doing all that stuff is
because we have right now a weak leader
and I'm gonna make my point you guys
ever watch National Geographic Tom and
you see a lion who's technically the
king of the jungle yeah but Heather gone
to a fight and he's limping and you see
that he's weak you know what the jackals
and the hyenas and all they all start to
look and they're like oh [__] they the
king is hurt so they start to bite at
his leg and they once they realize okay
he doesn't have any more everybody
attacks right now America is that
injured lion Russia is doing [__] that
they've never done so since how long Pat
China's literally flying [__]
balloons over over our nuclear missile
bases that I was stationed in the
borders wide open China's sending
fentanyl to kill our youth and get money
back from us we are such in a weird
position right now [__] that people
haven't done since the 70s it doesn't
look good and I'm genuinely for the
first time I'm like
something I'm not I wouldn't be
surprised if something did pop off where
somebody's like oh [__] somebody
somebody launched something that they
weren't supposed to launch and all
Health break soon because no matter what
you think I know for a fact working at a
nuclear missile base if one person
launches one it's over because
everybody's gonna Panic oh [__] can you
imagine that somebody did somebody
launched a new it's over it's over and I
feel like we're getting close to that
point because most people have power
Putin feels like he's getting surrounded
bro that's not good it's not a good time
I think when there was a Vinnie's right
about the vacuum of leadership and I
think we have a weak leader in America
right now and I think that that we are
still the greatest country in the world
and we can solve our problems we can
come together as a diverse people and
get that done but it needs strong
leadership and that leadership is not
just at the top the leadership is calls
on all of us to step up starting with
our schools I feel incredibly strong
about education and incredibly strong
about providing safe balanced education
and weak leadership at the top weak
leadership in the home weak leadership
at your school you make a great point
and it's it's there's a vacuum out here
that's just screaming let me ask a
question though here's a question the
question we started off with was Russia
you know Biden being in Ukraine not
going to East Palestine uh concerns of
Russia you know putting their weapons on
the ships seeing the fact that China is
uniting with Putin and saying hey we
will sell you lethal weapons for the
first time not like regular weapons
lethal weapons all of these things are
you know
going in the direction of could this
lead to an all-out War are we there or
are we not there yet sorry about that I
was I was reacting I thought you were
asking me about my response no I want to
know this story to the original question
going back here I think what is
happening right now is the west and
let's call it the East are fighting a
proxy war three in Ukraine and you have
to remember let's take a look at the
weapons that are being given have you
noticed but we will never give them
those tanks we'll give them some of
those we'll give them money for our
amendments we'll give money for small
arms we get money for grenade launchers
get money for but we won't give them
Stingers okay hell give them Stingers if
you notice that the level of weapons and
they keep making a point of it in each
one of the articles is but they're
giving them lethal now but we're not
going to give them these but we'll give
them those it's escalating and I feel
like it's a proxy World War that's being
fought in the Ukraine as both sides are
providing into a certain degree testing
weapon systems that they're giving to
ukraines and giving to Russia China is
giving stuff to Russia and the West is
giving stuff to Ukraine remember we
weren't going to give many planes at all
and and then they said Poland give them
give us your NATO planes please please
give us the better planes that we can
have and Paul and said well maybe it
will maybe I won't I think we're
fighting a proxy war and it's going one
step at a time a drip at a time on the
advanced weapons and Pat where's the
outrage the president of the United
States on President's Day mind you flew
to [__] Ukraine gave them another 500
million I don't think people people just
throw those numbers around 500 million
dollars okay East Palestine there's a
freaking new fish are dying dogs are
dying people can't drink the the water
where you know what America is right now
imagine having like you know your Dad's
sick at the house man he's he's God
forbid dying of cancer you have the
means to help him but we're like you
know what I'm gonna donate to like like
a charity that's are you where is that
outrage or what the [__] is I'm sorry
for my language what is what is going on
like I I don't get it I don't understand
how much money collectively have we
given to Ukraine 100
billion billion uh
what 100 that doesn't make remember we
had that talk Adam when what's her name
was here uh it's gonna it's getting it's
not gonna be a trillion seconds yeah she
said it was 100 trillion yeah think
about this a hundred billion dollars and
I do I don't give a damn I feel bad for
what's going on over there I don't care
about Ukraine I care about us what why
is putting America First such a bad
thing why why can't we come first in
Palestine my thought about this is I
don't understand why it's being ignored
what is on those trains and who owns
those trains that is able to to drop the
dime on the media and our political
leaders so that everybody ignores it
that I'm I am actually I'm actually
confused I'm not confused I think
somebody's dropped the dime and is
suppressing the whole story but how
effectively did they if it wasn't for
Twitter America wouldn't know and Pat
we've talked about this before I walked
in here how great is this show me uh
there's a documentary and two last year
December called white noise that the
movie is set in 1984 the exact a trail
derailment with toxic chemicals in East
Palestine if if we're not living in The
Matrix that's a fact that that happened
in this movie last year wait this this
is a you were this is what you were
doing I told you before you went a
little bit so we can see the stories
this was this was a movie uh in 1984 set
and it and in the movie there's a train
derailment in East Palestine and it
dumped chemical uh thing if that if that
is not insane like I I don't know what
is an Airborne Toxic Event I'm sorry is
that we what are the odds is that crazy
so so go back to this go back to this so
are we are we uh uh at a point so Putin
doesn't want NATO to keep getting
stronger NATO keeps acting acting like
uh Ukraine is part of NATO U.S and by
the way this is not a democratic thing
Mitch McConnell said the most important
thing we can do right now is support
Ukraine so it's not like it's a Democrat
yeah McConnell is supporting this
there's a few there's a lot of people
that are not supporting this Jimmy Dore
they had a uh a rally this Sunday in uh
what do you call a DC and there was a
bunch of people there Tulsa gabbards
there you know a bunch of we know you
know uh uh how DeSantis feels about this
how Trump feels about this a lot of
people are against constantly sending
resources to these guys but are we at
the Tipping Point where all of a sudden
boom because the way this is going to go
is the moment the first person goes like
you said earlier it's go time it's a
wrap there's no more looking back and
taking your time with it no what do you
think
yeah I think that's why it's so scary
you know it's a
I think it's it's a word something some
like a distant memory for Americans
currently so they don't really
understand how serious this thing is we
are playing with right now there's
actual possibility of war world war
three with the nuclear power country we
are somehow think it's not possible
and so like let our guard down
and also it's like our country's a mess
it's not really a strong position
everything is working the country is a
complete mess China is I mean their
ambition is destroying America North
Korea's only goal is destroying America
I don't know what he runs is it is it
true death upon America
but we're on the same literally that's
what they say math bad on because death
upon America they're pretty clear yeah
their only purpose in their life is
destroying America and they are
supporting Russia right now so what are
we doing I think that's so and I'm
raising a child like some I don't know
what kind of future that he's gonna have
but I think this is where people in
America's because they never experience
any difficulty in life they cannot
fathom that how easily this piece can go
away
and and he's not even democratically the
chosen like who decides that we can give
this much money to Ukraine like who
decides that isn't this like a democracy
I don't remember voting for that bill
yeah me neither it's like I thought this
was democracy
who who chose that it was okay to send
that much money
if I may um by the way we're about to
reach the one year anniversary of the
war in Ukraine so uh that's I think part
of the reason that's the reason that he
went over there on President's Day or
President's Day weekend the big guy went
over there I think regarding the amount
of money that's being spent that's an
entirely okay conversation to have
Congress has approved this budget uh
it's Foreign Affairs it's part of the
entire budget you know as you know Tom
the majority of our GDP of our budget
goes to Social Security Medicare
Medicaid that's where the vast majority
goes and then beyond that it goes to our
defense and then beyond that what Pat
touched on the other day was the
freaking interest we have to pay on the
amount of debt that we have so I think
it is incumbent on cities first and
foremost Chicago La New York to clean up
their own mess okay it's not the federal
government's job to clean up
homelessness I actually don't think that
homelessness is is something that we can
fix I think there's always going to be
people who are [__] up and there's
always going to be homelessness in every
country regardless but back to Ukraine I
think two things can be true at once I
think I and I stand
steadfast with this Charlie Kirk said it
the other day it is just entirely
immoral and not the right thing to do
for a country to invade a sovereign
country and invade their sovereignty you
just can't do that that's just not
anything that we stand for in America we
believe in democracy we believe in
borders we don't play that game and
that's
part of the reason that we're backing
Ukraine at the same time we can question
dude how much freaking money are we
spending these over here how much longer
are we going to do this if we learned
anything in Afghanistan it's like we
don't want to be in [__] Wars that
just never end how long is this going to
go and if it's the quote unquote
technical one-year anniversary of the
invasion but they've been doing this
thing since 2014 in Crimea so this is an
ongoing thing is this going to turn into
another Afghanistan I hope not and then
just breaking news right now is on Wall
Street Journal uh she chairman she of
China is planning to visit uh Moscow
today or this week and this is right
after Putin who has now officially
suspended the nuclear arms treaty with
the United States of America so these
are real life things Tom touched on this
proxy war this is this is escalating to
a point where we in America for the
first few months Ukraine support Ukraine
nobody gives a [__] about Ukraine
anymore like just live your life yeah at
this point the war is escalating it
people are dying I think a couple
hundred thousand people have died
there's something called diplomacy we
need to figure out who in America is
going to be the Diplomat to basically
provide diplomacy so we can end this
freaking War nobody wants it it's not a
great points I I mean I don't think it's
going to end anytime soon she's going to
go visit Russia which is and she's
probably going to bring the supply
balloon info and tell him all the [__]
that that I'm being serious show them
everything and then and then Adam Pat
you know what the start treaty that he's
saying he's not going to go and I think
we have I think it's uh 1550 uh between
us and Russia we can have or it might be
individual uh icbms that have the
re-entry system you know I mean that can
actually come in and land and hit where
they want he's backing out of that so
basically that's Russia saying we could
put these systems on whatever the hell
we want because bro Russia is the I
think we're one in Russia's number two
right Pat for nuclear Arsenal and threat
for them to say listen we're backing out
of this because we want to be able to
put more not not just the WarHeads the
re-entry system which tells it where it
could sit and where it could land and
that's dude I'm telling you right now
that is not a good team to be teaming up
is those two bro that's I'm telling you
it's not going to be good well one one
final point we have the luxury in
America to sit here on the other side of
the world and genuinely rest easy at
night if you're in Europe because one
thing I'll continue to remind you is the
entire EU supports this War I know the
entire EU so if you're Germany if you're
Poland if you're on that NATO border
you're the ones who literally would be
facing nuclear 100 death okay so if
they're still behind this as America we
are we taking their cues from them or
are they taking our cues from us or is
it a is it a symbiotic relationship I
don't know but if they're resting easy
at night uh I think we can too I mean I
don't know but what do we want out of
this world like what do we want do we
want the Putin to die like we want to
destroy very good question like what is
our goal of keep going this part I think
you nailed it on the head on me what is
the goal yeah we've set the precedent
hey we don't stand for this we've
entered this War I think you're
absolutely what's the point now yeah and
I I think we need to read into basically
what Biden is saying is that he's
reaffirming our relationship with
Ukraine and we're not stopping and I
would like to know what the ideal
outcome is for doing all this what what
else would it be maybe maybe Pat they
have a shitload of dirt on his ass
because we already know I'm just hold on
I'm just Wing I'm giving you a bunch of
options and you know what zelinski is
saying hey bro we got all we got all
that [__] on the laptop we got we got
all of it just keep giving us understand
could that be a little bit of a just
again Biden's War what Congress has
approved but Biden hold on Biden
basically gave Russia the remember when
he said you guys could do a little minor
incursion it won't really Biden gave
them the okay to just come on in bro
buying it from the beginning was like
come on in that's on record Biden gave
to Russia he said yeah we won't get that
mad if they do a minor incursion in
Ukraine he said that [__] live he
basically gave them the green light to
come that's your point my point is Biden
is compromised so for somebody to be
giving a country that much freaking
money just open Wallet all the time and
going to visit and kiss this guy's ass
there has to be other elements involved
I'm saying it's not just one thing but
she made a great Point why because
somebody answer me why yeah I think what
you're going to see in Russia Russian
will be held accountable fit invades and
it depends on what it does if it's one
thing like a minor incursion and then we
end up having to fight about the uh what
to do and do and not do like dude that's
giving somebody a green light go go you
could you could you could drop a couple
bombs just don't really go to war so how
do you say that good point you're making
there Vinnie thanks listen we're gonna
we're gonna learn what's gonna happen
with this uh with the 100 billion
dollars the point wasn't to fix
homelessness that's a mindset issue that
we're having there's a reason why it
keeps happening in LA to me if that's
policies is the real issue it's the
example to say Democrats if you claim
you care about homeless people as much
as you do this is what you could have
done with the money given to Ukraine
your cause your need your money could
have helped America but it went
elsewhere that was the point with the
homeless stuff that we're talking about
anyway so let's talk about this other
thing so
capitalism there's this guy out there I
don't know if you guys know or not his
name is Bernie Sanders
Bernie's he was on this show called face
of nation okay and she faced the nation
and she asks a very simple question of
him he's having an event right now
that's 95 that's being sold on
Ticketmaster Ticketmaster that just got
a bunch of heat so credit to her for
asking the question of Bernie and look
how uncomfortable it gets very quickly
promote this book it's okay to be angry
about capitalism and you're here talking
about it I understand we're not the bad
guys you're describing in the book when
it comes to Media but tickets for your
tour apparently are selling for 95 on
Ticketmaster which is Con accused of
anti-competitive behavior you know that
some of your Democrats are criticizing
them aren't you benefiting
you're trying to dismantle first of all
those decisions are made totally by the
publisher in the Bookseller I think
right yes I am just a humble Senator
go back a little bit go back a little
bit some tickets we're going on tour to
promote this book it's okay to be angry
about capitalism and
you're here talking about it I
understand we're not the bad guys you're
describing in the book when it comes to
Media but tickets for your tour
apparently are selling for 95 on
Ticketmaster which is Con accused of
anti-competitive behavior you know that
some of your Democrats are criticizing
them aren't you benefiting yourself
you're trying to dismantle first of all
those decisions are made totally by the
publisher in the Bookseller I think it
is one case we're in one place here in
Washington politics and pros and
independent books are charging some
tickets most of them I think forty
dollars fifty dollars and you get a book
as well so if you want to come you're
going to have to pay 40 bucks I'll throw
in the book for free
events but I don't make a nickel out of
these things
that is you wrote a book probably be the
same process
first of all just so you know I I have a
you know I've been through this with
Simon and Schuster and now we're going
through a penguin you get to say what
you want to participate in and what you
don't want to participate in do they
force you to go places like your book
that's coming out did they force you and
tell you you better
go sell tickets at Ticketmaster or else
you're fired did they tell you something
like that I mean and your book is a
bestseller it's not like your book sold
a thousand copies your book was a New
York Times bestseller it did and the
next one that's coming up right that's a
new one that's coming up it just came
out that just came yeah they don't force
you to do those things they're very
grateful that I want to do interviews
like they don't like they don't have an
authority you have to do this that's
right right like you just really all up
to me so if he doesn't want to do it he
could always have done like not doing it
Bernie secretly loves capitalism here's
what's so crazy about it watch this he
bashes capitalism writes a book on
capitalism while a capitalistic company
prints it
ships it publishes it sells it on Amazon
promotes it on social media and goes
talks about our major media companies
platform all started by capitalism but
capitalism sucks yeah yeah it's a
hypocrisy yeah it's like it's like Greta
Thunder the climate activist lover so
and she's there with her book she sold
you know how many thousands of trees got
killed and chopped down I think it's
because of this person that talks about
free education but if you want to get
edgy hit about what I think I'm going to
charge you yeah it's a comedy here's
what I think is happening with Bernie
he's too far deep when he had no money
when he started off as a senator
Congressman or mayor of whatever Vermont
yeah that story was fine it's okay hey
socialism Democratic socialism it's all
good now that he's 80 something years
old he's made his millions by the way
which is fine by the time you're [__]
80s
if you just contribute to your 401k and
make 150 Grand a year that's normal but
now that he's reached this worldwide
International certainly National Fame
and books are being sold of it and he's
speaking and it's like this his
popularity is at a grand scale I'm
assuming he's grappling with the money
and the fame and the success and the
notoriety versus no uh capitalism was
bad it's like yeah well where are you
yeah which one is it Bernie you gotta
pick a path like he owns Bernie's a
buddy
oh that's you with Bernie what are you
saying no I mean it's interesting
because he owns a multiple property the
idea of like not capital is not owning
anything so AOC and he should be the
first one denouncing all their
properties not owning anything sell it
all Tom actually has a very intimate
story with Bernie I don't know if you
want to tell the whole story
no he really does upstairs no watch this
it's actually pretty funny so a
colleague and I are in Vermont visiting
a uh a company in our industry uh the
industry that I was working at the time
and we as I'm going through metal
detector in the uh airport there's this
uh corn Mai there's kind of a silver
haired gentleman I look it's Bernie's
right behind me we walk the metal
detector yet and um I kind of bumped
shoulders with him over getting the bags
off and I said oh hello Senator hello
how are you and um we we walk a few
steps and my colleague says Hannah
stepped to the men's room real quick
right and Bernie goes in there so I'm
just waiting for my friend to come out
and he comes out and he says
I just said hi to Bernie Sanders where
while we were both standing there in the
bathroom oh well you were both uh yeah
relieving ourselves says he said hello
and then he farted incredibly loud
and I said oh so you know sort of
passing legislation and
and they walk out and
so my colleagues goes wow that's a
forever story I said yeah you forever
can say at the Burlington Vermont
airport did he say excuse me he said you
know I don't think he did
Bernie that that's disgusting but listen
when you hear stories like this and and
a guy is again he's human
this is this is the great part about
capitalism sometimes you don't even have
to debate the other person you just
bring them you let them talk and then
eventually like oh there's a leak oh
there's a leak oh there's a leak it's
like go ahead tell us why you believe in
socialism yeah tell us why you're
building the communism Bingo that
doesn't work you're using a capitalistic
platform to do what you're doing here
were you gonna say something in this
case in the middle of a leak there was a
fart so it really was I don't think you
could beat that so now let's go to the
next story which is should we go let's
do Disney time I think you got something
to say about Disney Disney man and uh
Disney layoffs what page is that 10
is it a page 10 story or is it a yeah
you don't need those biography return to
office plan may cause long-term harm
workers say thousands of Disney
employees
have a signed petition that is pushing
back on a company's return to office
plan arguing that the four day work week
requirement will unintended consequence
will have unintended consequences for
the company the petition has garnered
over 2300 signatures from employees
across Mickey Mouse's businesses the
workers claim that the Mandate is likely
to have unintended consequences
replace okay go ahead Tom what are your
thoughts on this year with what Disney's
doing well first of all this is a group
of employees that are coming out
protesting the four day work week four
days and remember Iris had two things
we're a creative company come together
to discuss creative ideas and come
together for mentorship and be
identified as potential for management
this is not Igor telling everybody you
will be in the office 60 hours five days
remember this this goes back it's
actually a month ago everybody seems
pretty reasonable but now you've got 2
300 Disney people that say no no that's
even that's too much we are hard to
replace talent and here it comes
represent vulnerable communities that
was what they said so this happens about
two days ago to be exact yesterday
Wall Street guidance is given and Disney
says well you need to brace yourself
because I think there will be actually 5
000 additional workers laid off wow
that's what they said yesterday so can I
be Bob Iger will you be head of HR yeah
okay hey Vinnie yeah Bob here listen
um I may have to lay off 5 000 more
people
okay we gotta pick 5 000 more people to
lay off uh I got a question for you yeah
if you have that petition handy
I think I have it right here I got it
right here all right Perfect all right
put them on the list tell all those
people that don't want to come to work
that they can work from home for
somebody else got you have a nice day
thank you I bet I think this is so
ironic that people are coming forward
when I thought that Iger made a very
measured good points about coming back
to work on a four day plan some of you
are in traffic in Burbank California
it's just four days and then they go
there and then Disney behind the scenes
is looking for other expenses and so the
unattended consequences a bunch of
people going oh man I signed that thing
yeah
wow Vinnie no I just it's I'm I just
felt I just felt really cool like I had
like an HR job
[Music]
back in my office yeah I actually think
that these conversations are actually
becoming more and more important the
overarching conversation is this concept
of work-life balance and I think that
Disney is just sort of in the crosshairs
of a greater conversation this isn't the
first time we've discussed four day work
weeks certain countries I think I
believe has started to implement this
Portugal being won
um versus what you see for instance like
in countries like Japan you see people
that like are so burnt out because their
entire life is just spent working that
they it's acceptable to just sleep in
the streets or they have like areas we
can sleep so I'm actually totally okay
with whether it's countries whether it's
municipalities whether it's corporations
completely having this dialogue this
this you know do you live to work or do
you work to live this is this is a
conversation I think is okay you know
this isn't like nonsensical BS this is
people's lives and their livelihood and
I think these kind of conversations are
are are totally acceptable
any thoughts
I mean I come from communist North Korea
there's no weekends right we are
revolutionaries we have to work wow
every single hour from 5 a.m to 10 p.m
wow so even your child five years old we
all have to be in the first labor I I
just I don't know like you go to work
there's AC there's indoor bathroom
there's a clean water what's the
complaint you get paid for it so there's
no work-life balance in North Korea
whatsoever I mean we don't know the word
but I think it's just so weird like
Omega is so soft people are so lazy can
I ask you what actually I think what
she's saying yes if Bob Iger wants
people to work seven days a week move
your headquarters to North Korea yeah
exactly well you you might be the
perfect person to ask this question
because we covered this the other day on
the podcast where by generation the the
level of Pride and patriotism in America
has decreased yeah so Baby Boomers was
in the 70-something percentile gen xers
were in the 60s or 50s Millennials were
in the 40s and gen Z 16
proud to be America you're from freaking
North Korea I mean the bottom of the
barrel as far as human rights go how
good do we have it here in America based
on your experience all over the world I
mean this is a pure miracle I think like
I went to school at Columbia with the
generous gen Z their dream is destroying
America
right and bring the Communist Revolution
into this country this is Colombia is
this is Colombia not Colombia yeah
Colombia Pablo Escobar this is Colombia
University in New York Colombia let me
pronounce it correct Manhattan with our
friend Gad said basically was uh talking
about the wokism let's go so go ahead
right so I think this is what it shocks
me capitalism so
it's so compassionate
they created the term human rights I
mean Columbus Nursing we don't even know
that that's a concept like when I heard
about animal rights in South Korea it's
like what do you mean my puppy rights I
did not know I had a right there there's
so much human rights here that we got
animal rights How You Like Me Now yeah
so
I don't know why would you want to tear
down this ethical most amazing system
you use the word soft we are so soft
yeah explain that go further on why you
think we are so soft here is because we
have it so good here
yeah I mean they complain of having too
much food like they complain about not
having actual problem they have to make
a problem out of nowhere like out of
like just literally thin air they
created Injustice like their Injustice
like there's a 10 000 pronouns and you
cannot pronounce them you cannot
remember now you're a bigot that's their
Injustice what were the pronouns that
you were using in North Korea
that's a really good question I don't my
my brain went there what what is their
what is the policy on homosexuality and
you know but like what I mean there's
obviously gay people there how does how
does the Supreme Leader and all them how
do they how do they do that are people
trying I don't have I have no idea what
it's like over there so I think that's
where North Korea is so different they
denies love between people they did not
give us a vocabulary so my mother never
told me that she loved me so we don't
have the word for love we don't have
wonderful human rights and we don't have
the word for gay
so that means you you cannot even know
what that is oh my God oh my God so if
you see somebody dancing you're like
okay that guy is not one of us like he's
weird is that what their mindset is yeah
you're now allowed to dance
you're not allowed to sing other than
the propaganda song oh my God you go to
prison if you move your body freely can
you imagine being a Jill pet like what
are you in here for I moonwalked and now
I'm doing 20. and that's cool it's also
you're not allowed to make love to your
wife standing up because it could lead
to Dancing Yeah
when you talk about the labor camps what
is like an a day for someone that's in a
labor camp like what is it just wake up
eat and this all day till you're so
you're passing out what's what's what is
it because people people say that's like
one of the worst experiences so to be in
when you're sent to concentrating Camp
the first thing you cannot do is why am
I here
okay no question why yeah if you do you
get executed oh my God so they just it's
a three generation punishment so you
don't even know who messed up in your
three generation family that I end up
here so you just show up to the prison
camp first thing you learn is you never
ask why you're there and you learn you
never look at the guard's eyes because
you're not human being anymore
you are the sub himo so you cannot look
at their eyes and they rape women
constantly they don't last more than
three months they let them clean those
nuclear debris oh my Nuclear debris and
they're getting raped and they they do
the biochemical testing on these inmates
like the Nazis did for in the gas
chamber and testing on this biochemical
weapons and you're saying so you're
saying so somebody in your three
generation family could have done
something way down you don't even know
what the hell and just grab you and they
put you in yeah all I said a few decades
before and it came out now their grandpa
one day may be drinking with friends
like in the 40s before anything happened
and one day maybe I'm not sure so sure
about communism and that came out of
somebody later reported remember the
conversation in this 80s goes to police
and said I remember he sat in the 40s
now you end in a prison camp don't you
imagine that one more question regarding
um capitalism communism if there's a
greater case example of communism versus
capitalism it is exactly what happened
in Korea versus North Korea and South
Korea if you look at South Korea
um who basically during the Korean War
align themselves with the USA in the 50s
and you know what is it the 38th
parallel and then North Korea aligned
themselves with the Soviet Union and
China and China yeah and if you look at
South Korea they are almost top 10 in
GDP in the world I think they're
numbered 10 or 11 right now yeah versus
you have North Korea they're not even on
the Spectrum so what have you
experienced just you've been to South
Korea I assume yeah of course you lived
there so the the the the benefits of
capitalism and democracy and everything
that kind of accompanies that in South
Korea versus the hellhole that is North
Korea there's no greater case example if
you would expound upon that yeah I think
that's it it's nothing about your
genetics or your culture or and it or
like anything tradition it's all about
Freedom or or communism tyranny right
when we let the individuals be free and
they innovate they week worth and we can
achieve like Miracles and look at North
Korea the same exact potential we create
like living hell
so yummy can you go there's no way can
you when's the last time you visited
South Korea and is there any like can
you go there and if you do go there what
what is that situation the intelligence
don't like me coming back because I'm on
the killing list of Kim Jong-un it's
embarrassing for them if I get assassin
in South Korea so wow and I'm pretty
sure they have people oh yeah just
waiting for somebody like you and what's
up what's the population of just Korea
as a whole so North Korea they don't
even know the population so many of them
dying of starvation so they say 24
million but more realistic or something
21 million the population hasn't grown
but South Korea now is 50 million people
almost okay so you're saying so what
what is that North you said about 30 21
and so you're the of the 290 here
congratulations here's what I want you
to do I want you to go visit South Korea
I've enjoy your time to spend one week
okay and then I want you to sneak into
North Korea I could do that and then I
mean report from there okay and you want
to give us the differences I get 100
yeah okay your ticket is booked enjoy
this is a satellite map of Korea at
night look at North Korea oh the lights
it's just dark yeah
oh my God if does it if that isn't
capitalism Innovation free enterprise I
was watching I'm uh speaking at an event
last week in Vegas palazzo's event and
the the Wonder speakers was a uh stress
speaker he's talking about there's good
stress there's bad stress you know all
this depression anxiety all this stuff
and I showed him a video I said I saw a
video from 50 Cent and it was the most
powerful point he made 50 Cent said
being depressed is a luxury
if you're depressed it's because you can
afford to be depressed he says go
explain it to the husband that's got
three kids working two jobs he doesn't
have any time to be depressed he's
working seven days a week any of these
guys that say they're depressed this is
50 Cent you can afford it it's a luxury
because if your back was against the
wall you would not have the luxury of
being depressed it's a completely
different perspective so sometimes
depression has caused uh for people who
have way way too much time on their
hands because they're not being
productive here you are somebody that
just came to America who escaped gotten
at an age that most of us have a hard
time letting our kids be outside by
themselves at that age let alone escape
a country as a girl and find a way to
come out here you know you know the
first speech you gave the one that was
publicized and it was how many views did
that thing get like 80 million views 70
million views almost a billion once her
first speech when her story was told
worldwide of where was that at that
first speech Island in Ireland one
billion views I don't know if you've
seen this or not when she's younger
telling the story super she's shaking
talking emotional obviously at this
point this is how many years since that
speech how many years ago was it when
you give that 80 years eight years from
giving that speech to where she's at
today the the the this is it yeah this
was it when this message was given eight
years ago to where she's at right now oh
yeah one young world oh my yeah pause
the audio there you go yeah the audio is
the one that we don't want to hear if
you can just go to see what she looked
like as a when she's telling the story
uh uh right there that's her telling the
story a billion views later right there
wow you only Park to now hear coming out
with her book her second book to share
the story of what happened on how more
Americans can become grateful and
realize how lucky you are to be living
in the greatest country in the world you
only thank you for your bravery thank
you for are willing to share your story
I'm sure it's not the most exciting
thing you want to do or you go up there
and say Let Me Tell my story again for
the hundredth time over and over and
over again but sometimes it takes
somebody like you to tell that story for
people to realize how lucky they are to
be living in a place like this so if you
haven't ordered a book yet just came out
a week ago while time remains a North
Korean Defector search for freedom in
America Rob let's put the link below in
chat and description for people to go
out there and get it yomi are you also
right now creating content if the
audience wanted to find you what will be
the best place for them to find you
first of all I want to say my book is
competing with the Prince Harry oh
really really love that I mean they have
a lot of struggles going on their life
is so hard
challenging that is funny Prince Harry's
life yeah
I'm sorry but they've gone through a lot
way more than you true victims
yeah
you know South Park made a video about
making fun of them and Megan got
offended oh really yeah Megan got
offended saying this is not funny you
know offended about them making fun of
their lives yeah anyways oh we'll put
all the information for people to be
able to find you as well go get her book
uh we're at the end of it we're gonna go
have lunch with you here in the morning
Thursday this Thursday that we got we
got the live podcast
we're two days away for the live podcast
we'll see you guys for those who'll be
here you'll be the first to celebrate
the podcast at the new studio with the
Cigar Lounge can't wait to see everybody
there take everybody we'll see you guys
in two days bye bye-bye